what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
all right what's going on guys this is
Robin I'm actually periscoping while I'm
recording this if you guys don't know I
have periscope which lets me live stream
to Twitter uh and you could find me
you know periscope calm or whatever it
is slash comments explain anyway just
follow me on Twitter then copies display
and you'll see about periscope there
anyway I wanted to have this discussion
about why spider-man is so popular right
I mean there's all different kinds of
levels of like the argument when it
comes to spider-man's popularity like
there are some people that will say
spider-man is as popular if not more
popular than like Superman and that is a
whole different discussion for whole
nother time that's one that we're not
even gonna get into here because I'd
open the kettle of beans and quite
frankly I doesn't want to open but when
it comes to the idea of spider-man and
what he's capable of
his popularity will ensure that he
stands the test of time as one of the
most iconic superheroes ever but the
question is why why is spider-man so
popular so let's wind the clock back so
1938 a Superman shows up for the very
first time and just takes the world by
storm I mean it's it was nutsi I mean
going back and reading articles of when
he first appeared people's reactions to
it it was it was something that had
never really been seen before a
superhero that was virtually bulletproof
who could jump at insanely high levels
who could run insanely fast you know he
was bulletproof and the peak of human
conditioning ah was new to everybody had
a costume had a cape you know that kind
of thing it made it look like he flew it
was really cool I mean the power of
flight wouldn't come until a couple
years after his character was created
but on the whole Superman set a whole
new standard when it came to superheroes
in this new medium but on the whole
Superman's popularity stemmed from the
fact that he fought on behalf of the
common man you know Superman's early
stories saw him fighting against you
know jewel thieves which protected store
owners saw him fighting against
murderers which protect the people they
were trying to murder you know it had
him fighting against government
corruption which protect the citizen
body had him fighting against corrupt
corporations and other things like that
and the more Superman became popular the
more characters that were created in
order to capitalize on that popularity
which meant that as time went on we
eventually got Wonder Woman and Aquaman
and Shazam this little kid Billy Batson
who would shout the word Shazam and
become basically somebody who is
equivalent to Superman we got heroes
like the flash you know Jay Garrick the
original Green Lantern Alan Scott and
despite the fact that their own powers
varied despite the fact that their
origin stories were different from those
of Superman at the end of the day they
were still superheroes
man was the only real exception he was a
little bit darker he was a little more
gritty more of an antihero than anything
else but all roads led to Rome he was
still saving the day at the end of his
college just by doing it through a
different means the popularity of those
traditional superheroes led to the
introduction of younger superheroes of
course Billy Batson had already been
established as a little kid but when he
became Shazam it wasn't a little kid
with powers who was a grown adult with
powers and that was the essence of comic
book superheroes back then the heroic
quality as it was deemed by callable
creators was something that was only
attainable by adults only adults had the
wisdom to be superheroes only adults had
the wisdom that really understand right
from wrong
now sidekicks were introduced which
introduced the teenage element into
comic books but at the end of the day
sidekicks weren't viewed as superheroes
sidekicks were viewed as superheroes and
training Dick Grayson Robin was training
to become as good as Batman
Aqualad was training to become as good
as Aquaman Kid Flash was training to
become as good as the flash that was the
role they played in comics and this was
designed to mirror real life even in
this day and age as adults we look
around and say man you know when I was a
teenager I really thought I knew the
ways of the world but I don't you know I
didn't know how things worked when I was
16 years old I was just young and dumb
now they're all different walks of life
and there are seven 16 year-olds who
were more experienced than thirty year
olds but on the whole a larger majority
of people as adults know more and
understand more than they did when they
were teenagers and comic books reflected
that the reason why spider-man is so
popular is because he broke that
transition he broke that change he broke
that mold almost in its entirety instead
of spider-man training to become a
superhero
under some other greater superhero out
there he was just suddenly thrust into
the world of Heroes Captain America
grabbed his shield and led the Avengers
under the mighty charge against Hydra or
advanced idea mechanics you know
Superman come on Justice League we can
do this you know and they he led the
charge of the Justice League against
some villain but spider-man never had
that he tried to join the Fantastic Four
his first issue and they turn him down
instead the training of spider-man came
by way of the death of his uncle Ben the
real world slapped him in the face so
hard that suddenly he just had to adapt
he had to get used to things he had to
suddenly realize what it meant to be a
hero
there was no Captain America saying all
right spider-man let's go sit down and
let me teach you everything you need to
know about being a superhero he had to
figure it out on his own
he had his aunt made to guide him and to
be his moral compass but he was
literally just flying by
his pants almost the entire time that
relatability extended to the average
average comic reader because which one
of us can never really say that we
understand life so perfectly we know
everything we need to do in order to
achieve success as we make our way
through they're not at all
everybody's flying by the seat of their
pants everybody's taking it one day at a
time everybody makes mistakes realizing
they screwed up and then tries to
correct those maybe they can maybe they
can't but nobody has a perfect
understanding about how the way the
world works and spider-man reflected
that the other half of this is teenagers
empowering teenagers the largest space
for comic book readership and comic
books was teenagers I mean granted as
the years go on teenagers who started
reading grew into adults who continued
reading but the influx of come above
readers was almost always teenagers and
he was usually always young boys but the
idea was that when they were reading
comic books back in the you know 1940s
and 1950s and the early 1960s if they
were reading superheroes they weren't
the star of the show they were just
along for the ride they were just
learning how to become a superhero
spider-man came along and said no no no
all right teenage readers you're not
along for the ride you're on the rod you
are the star of the show you're not
dancing next to the main attraction you
are the main attraction and it empowered
teenagers because it made them feel like
they were important it made them feel
like they matter it made them feel like
they were the reason why there's so much
success it was almost like an encounter
book adaptation to the success of comic
books comic books grew in popularity and
stayed popular because teenagers read
them and now it almost felt like for a
lot of teenagers or at least I would
imagine anyway that their work their
effort had been it was basically being
recognized it was being paid off and so
because of that when teenage boys sat
down and they read amazing fantasy
number 15 they would see this kid who
was like nerdy just like they were this
kid who was being picked on just like
they were this kid who couldn't get the
girl just like they couldn't but instead
of just having this comic that says yep
man life is rough and this just gonna
kind of be that way
suddenly Peter Parker gets bitten by a
radioactive spider on a science trip and
now that bully Flash Thompson gets
what's coming to him now his nerdiness
helps him to become a better superhero
and oh my god ooh the girls loved him he
was everything those teenage boys
aspired to be now that was a teenage
element that was it the teenage aspect
but teenage reading isn't enough to keep
a comic book running forever you also
have to maintain the readers who are
adults
you know grew up reading comic books as
teenagers and kept on going as adults
and that's where the other half of
Spider Man success came into play
Spider Man was a dude who was just
struggling day in and day out
The Avengers never had financial issues
Tony Stark the ruling like the richest
man in the world was a founding member
of the Avengers team and he just
bankrolled the Avengers he gave him a
place to live
gave them a base of operations he never
worried about money when he read The
Avengers comics when you sat down and
read Avengers number four where they
discovered Captain America for the very
first time when you read Avengers number
10 or Avengers number 20 or Avengers
number 30 the topic of all Man guys like
rents do how are we gonna pay that that
never came up it was just the Avengers
flying headlong into some adventure
against Loki or be Incredible Hulk or
some you know small-time villain that
was created just for the story there was
no discussion about bills there was no
discussion about money there was no
discussion about oh man I wonder if I'm
gonna be able to take my girlfriend on a
date tonight but that discussion was in
spider-man that discussion was in
spider-man as Peter Parker was defeating
a villain and then heading back home and
then realizing rent was due that day and
he was late but he didn't have any money
and he didn't know how he was gonna pay
it that discussion came up when he was
trying to figure out where he was gonna
take when Stacy did dinner because he
didn't really have any didn't really
have any money and that resonated with
people especially like in this day and
age because college kids struggle all
over the place but the idea of
struggling financially is not a new
thing it's not a post you know 2008 real
economic crisis thing it's always been
that way there's always been people who
have struggled financially there's
always been people who have been trying
to figure out how they're gonna take it
from one day to the next there's always
been people who have boyfriends and
girlfriends significant others and are
trying to figure out how they're going
to go with them to enjoy an evening
without having enough money to actually
enjoy it lavishly and that was a core
part of the spider-man stories house
rent gonna get paid how are the bills
gonna get paid where is this going
how long is he really gonna be
spider-man this is compounded by the
fact that for the most part because
spider-man didn't have the same kind of
grand huge villains like The Avengers or
The Incredible Hulk or Thor had a lot of
the the superhero community didn't take
him wildly seriously he wasn't like oh
man we've gotta have spider-man on our
side it wasn't like the Avengers were
facing off against some threat and said
oh my god guys you know who's gonna help
us
spider-man you know that almost never
happened instead it was God guys man
we're being absolutely crushed but were
the Earth's Mightiest Heroes we'll deal
with it on our own because we have four
and we have Captain America we've got
like some of those successful
powerhouses and comics what do we need
spider-man
even then among the the audience base
the casual person who knew of spider-man
but didn't really read him myself
included spider-man was never taken
seriously okay yeah cool spider-man he's
a guy that dresses in a suit and climbs
up walls
rahu I'm gonna go read my x-men with a
mutant that can work reality on a
universal scale but was so funny about
that is like spider-man's spider-sense
the one ability that he has that alerts
him to danger before it happens is the
one thing that makes them more
successful than virtually any other
character out there as one of the
reasons why you whenever you have major
crossover events for the most part
spider-man's usually the last man
standing spider-man's intelligence his
wittiness added kind of a freshness to
comic books where he would be going
against villains he'd cracked jokes he'd
throw him off kilter it wouldn't be like
Captain America where he took himself
super seriously I just started beating
the heck out of him with his shield
spider-man would poke fun at Doctor
Octopus while he was beating the crap
out of him he would poke fun at electro
while he was beating the crap out of him
now of course we would find out in later
years the reason why spider-man did that
is because it was designed to throw his
villains off kilter they're taking
themselves seriously but if they believe
that spider-man's not taking themselves
seriously they'll get angry and in their
anger they'll stop fighting rationally I
think that was explained during amazing
spider-man renew your vows as part of
secret Wars but I'm sure is probably
explained before that but those elements
are what made spider-man so relatable
and so popular to humor the the simple
relatability of struggling financially
trying to find a good job the
relatability of not knowing when bills
are gonna get paid the relatability of
trying to be taken seriously by the rest
of the superhero community and even
coming book readers themselves that's
the reason why spider-man will always
stand the test of time that's the reason
why spider-man will always be one of the
most iconic superheroes in the history
of comic books even if its successor ops
off even if in 50 years
spider-man's popularity is virtually
gone and no one reads him anymore
and Marvel cancels him the legacy he
created will live on forever people will
always say yep spider-man I remember him
it'll always just kind of be an
intrinsic facet of the superhero
community but with that being said guys
we're gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an end if you are new here two
comments explained make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become part of the
robb core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]